I just do this one oh no I don't have a
memory card
I love it so yeah as I was saying before
this is actually based off Japanese
cartoon series and I went round my
friends my best friend's house the other
day and she was feeling a bit ill and we
were supposed to go out for breakfast
and I was like ah well can I just stay
in I like have a coffee with you at
least since she was like yeah sure
and then I was like can we watch
Gregorio show we just sat down for about
an hour just watching because they're
all on YouTube so you can watch them
already low-quality but who cares so
basically yeah it's like a really messed
up game that my mum thought would be
good for me to play when I was a kid
buh-buh-buh-buh fam
[Music]
that's Gregory
yeah yeah yeah okay so this is just like
the introductory video so I'll just get
off this stop stop
where's okay great
so yeah let's play well I don't have a
load game so let's do new game
I just love this game I think it's
revolutionary honestly
it should have been hung by now I saw a
bright light before me it was the hotel
do you need a room for the night
thank you okay let's put my name in
I was honestly so obsessed in this game
when I was a kid I just would not I
wouldn't stop playing it I wouldn't stop
writing stories about it in primary
school which actually got me in trouble
this is they've I bet to my mom like
it's your daughter okay
yeah I was just obsessed with this and I
just love III it blew my mind that at
the beginning they spoke in both male
and female and then you chose and then
it carried on it gave me like a male or
a female character I was like Oh cuz
there weren't many games that did that
back back in those days
[Music]
just lost your mind
hmm so when I paid this is my friend Amy
she was like I hate his laugh
come on now have appe this games
Whistler daughters sir remember
by the way let me know if you need me to
change the audio by the way
I'm used to small bodies
hey mantas good luck there buddy oh yeah
here you go
sorry I totally forgot about that that's
the game audio there yeah let me know if
that's too loud or whatever oh my god
these graphics though um okay so the
funny thing he was is that if you
actually do find the animated version of
this online it looks exactly like this
it was just they were just little cubes
so I guess it was the easiest way to
make the game but this game is really
cool because basically you have like an
insanity meter you go outside you can
peek through doors and the whole game
mechanic is that you kind of need to
just get to know everyone's daily
rituals so then you can steal their
souls because you're kind of in limbo
right now in a limbo hotel and you give
souls to the Grim Reaper
so you'll meet like loads of new
characters and oh sorry won't we
derpy derp derp and you have to like
take their souls
[Music]
you you're the one who moved in next
door yesterday aren't we owed to talk to
you yes go get the key that's on the
counter in the lobby and bring it okay
so she's CI pg-13 and that's like the
main thing you'll be doing this game I
think I just love games where you don't
fight anything I don't know I think I
just love games where it's it's like no
I'm just nosy no I'm just nosy because I
remember I absolutely loved Sutton
helpful for the people reason as well
yeah - oh this is so unique like this
you'll see why the room next door was a
beautiful creature with the manager of
this hotel
I simply well I'm gonna get it from you
Gregory
oh it's 12:30 this is what I mean you
need to know their daily rituals and
their daily routines so then if you need
something you know what to do or where
they're gonna be about time I made the
rounds of the hotel and then you kind of
get this diary and you write down all
their movements in the diary and you've
got a chronic fatigue where they're
gonna be in what they're gonna do
because eventually they will try to kill
you
and you have to kind of run away from
everyone it's just not fun
okay bye keep walking don't watch me
[Music]
thank you very much
I implore you though if you enjoy this
or like some of you are saying Joe you
said you liked the look of it the style
of it this is please just watch it
afterwards
Gregory stop being a nosy little thing I
know I am I may ask Emily I'm doing and
the thing let's just wait for him to go
you can go in first person mode as well
which actually makes it oh I remember
now if you go in first person mode and
you follow someone and they don't
realize you're there you can hear them
talk to themselves which also gives you
clues on kind of how to defeat them and
where they're about to go and stuff like
that
they probably have to show me that
anti-gay mechanic okay and just I
remember the doors in this game are so
loud to like let you know that people
are coming and it just freaked me out
[Music]
I'm so hungry
[Music]
that we Disney Kosambi do you think I'm
scary
do you guys I don't I don't need your
sympathy okay I am ready missus in this
hotel are planning to keep you trapped
here for all eternity
yes we're not going to give up their
souls thought easily I let you listen to
this and it's important what have to
know their weak points if you want to
get those souls back yeah first you've
got to scope out their weak points
without them noticing there'd be a
sneaky sneak up on us peeking
the keys okay now even though that's
kind of wise it's you at the beginning
but whatever you ready then go ahead and
try peeking into my room
you see me yeah I can see about one yes
a weak point is same count really so
this is what happens when you peek in on
them
[Music]
so you have to do it for a certain
amount of time and to hear the Brahma
Brahma Brahma and that shows you that
their thought processes has ended and
then you probably written it down your
book or no you harboring it done but it
has this other really cool function
mechanic that so you're you're peeking
but yeah if you move too fast you start
to freak out wherever it does that and
then they will know instantly they'll
hear you from outside so they'll know
that you're watching them and they'll if
they want to kill you they'll come up to
come out to see if you're there and if
it's like it's not there just run away
okay guys why are you listening I'm
gonna make you decide what was the cat
thinking about this is up to you know I
already know the answers I've made this
so many times so what what do you think
it was this is when you're like oh I
wasn't watching Oh Joshua said it
reminds you of another hot children's
horror show called Chris's hell's up
with some kids oh dude I used to love
that show
that wasn't a game was it I used to love
that show yeah I used to love anything
that was big same so I'm like same I
mean I am still the same I was always
the same yeah she thinks it's ice cream
do you know do you know or Yeltsin to
the cat right are you sure it's ice
cream
Oh Troy ice cream it was not ice cream
guys what was it
Kunis is Yasmin I don't think mecha
zombie wants to eat me what do you think
is it banana lemon I think I can't
actually remember exactly watch what the
cat said cuz I already know the answer
it's Bruce it was like something sweet
and smooth not too hot but not too cold
pretty sure that's what Mike is over
there
come on doors have to sit here and wait
yeah hey right on TV thank you I was
forget my friends for a second trigger
yes sweet and yeah exactly
not too cold okay yeah yeah he got it
I'm tiny robot nice little guys thank
you see all she wanted was for me to
answer her little question not even give
her food okay
twelve souls and all you must find the
guests in this hotel is caring
alright guys do you wanna ask the
questions I guess I will answer ask the
questions for you so that you know
what's going on so what is the lost soul
let's let Nico's on we tell us Oh how
did the noise the soul that does not
sound like at all
I made of drifting hearts and faded
hopes you'd better be careful or you
might end up the same who are the guests
to escape from their inescapable pain
the residents of Gregory House have
chosen a life of endless wandering they
love to see other people suffer you'd
better look out for yourself so beta D
is limo and they just haven't passed
Anya why are the gas carrying Souls
around good question they took the lost
souls without permission from the
original owner and who was this original
owner there's no need for you to worry
about that
I wouldn't know more rather dull it's a
place to soothe your tired soul yes but
you'll find out soon enough
just what kind of place it is just being
all misty reading to deliver those Souls
back to death I'm going to sleep though
you're going to meet him in your dreams
at that case you should sleep on the bed
if you want to hand the solos over today
sounds logical okay so I guess I go to
sleep now
[Music]
did you manage to pick up any Souls yep
[Music]
brought me a lost soul already hey
thanks a lot here I'll snap your card
for you okay keep finding them then
bringing them back get one go to sleep
and I'll catch up with you when your
dreams
Thanks Michael says how can I talk with
this mouth sewn shut I'd like to think
that it's like tried to talk so much
over the years that it's every time it
just kind of loosens a little bit you
know how you like and it's like its
wounds are just kind of stretched and
that's how it's talking ah Chuck Gaines
I love you you're so inspiring to listen
as I'm considering games about them as a
career and I hope you do a QA on how you
accomplish so much for game spammin
thank you jack games I think my last
video might help you out quite bad
sneeze it's about how didn't make the
most out of uni if you go but also it's
kind of like my journey but because I
didn't go straight to uni and I did
stuff before you knew that I think
really helped but thank you no it's
really nice is he swedish i am not a
clue he's death okay apparently they're
the sewn up Kat was in my room while I
was sleeping and left me a note a little
bit unnerving but
I'm gonna think about it you sleep well
I've got to talk to you about you know
what oh no captain
this is so weird so I used to play this
as a kid and I was just like this lizard
Brady likes blood but she gets very
happy around blood but you'll see you'll
see I'm gonna get demonetised
oh this is
yep loves to drop a lot she loves the
drop it's two doors down about getting
people's souls
Michael you are not wrong I think every
I don't know it's at the time when I was
a kid but now now it okay so let's let's
do so that the hints are basically gonna
be like pink but don't move around
they're gonna hear you work for this
yeah
sounds sounds will give you away so was
that listen closely
yeah yeah blue flames mean that they
have a soul be city I can tell you that
knocking on doors faces oppress square
if you knock on a door when there's
someone in the room the personal
tomorrow that's coming out of the way
got it cheers someone stepped on it and
had an accident
[Music]
where's that brat James the one who has
to clean up all of your messes
so breathe again
hey Catherine so because she's got soul
and you want in you uh Yacktman x16 me
most terrible things to you think I'll
make your job harder by running away yes
so they'll run away until you get their
song and then then they will try and
kill you who are we in this game you you
were this girl because I chose Gary at
the beginning but that's not you out to
a bonnet you're you're also a lost soul
in limbo Hotel and you've been given a
body by Gretta from Gregory and the only
way out of limbo is to collect all the
fetal souls and give them back to death
and then they'll let you go back to life
that's fun I think this is the fastest
you can go yeah
so a lot of places locked at the moment
but they become unlocks as many people
come into the hotel I think I know it's
- I see him go around the long way what
are you doing oh he's so annoying so
basically this this little idiot well
follow you around if he sees you and if
you do anything he's just gonna grass
you into Gregory if we stop peeping on
anyone you like
go and tell Gregory and then you'll have
to stop peeping but he does leave you a
little bit leave me alone bugger off go
away he basically just gets bored after
a while go away
[Music]
dude yeah yeah by Danes the state these
controls I'm just gonna use them by good
start building up a rep of what people
are doing think about food obviously
fools thank you I'm fine who is that as
I Catherine
at the moment it's easy because
everyone's just scared of me and say run
Catherine Brown get off she goes
let's go into her bedroom see what it's
like blood on the floor
mm-hmm obviously why does that not
surprise me
I can't if I want to oh I think I can
hide in that closet
somehow and then wait for her to come in
if she is gonna come in then a gift
blood yeah there's the blood under her
bed very carefully like safety quickly
and so the clock - actually the time but
you actually have an insanity meter
which hasn't started yet
so that'll start I think after you get
Catherine's soul and the time depicts
how crazy you are
and also just like other things in the
game to be fair this game is a it's just
got a lot of potential what it is I wish
they would peek into them
okay Catherine is that you again so they
give you hints when you're doing that so
I'll just tell you anyway because I
already know what to do if I can find
the bin
oh I know where the pin is
so basically you saw James the young one
through the banana peel on the ball
that's what we need to do and we go away
that's what we need to do - Catherine
get the banana peel tripper and everyone
has a different way of being killed
can't kill me game guess so they can
definitely kill you though you can't do
any collectables yeah I guess because we
don't have the Mac Romania thing on yet
thanks for subscribing rotten TV are you
here and yeah I want you there
I don't know why you here I think you
again how funny
did the did the thingy come up to the
little thing in the game then I'm not
speaking right am i yeah yeah you you
bugger off James I don't wanna hear from
you
[Music]
that's how this looks see he's in here I
just want it now I'm hungry yeah sorry I
kind of took that key okay hopefully he
won't follow me again so I read he's
gonna be bothered a key open an appeal
I'm doing banana peel
we used to figure out where she is
oh good good he must have a kind of time
thing on him then so if he is both do in
the past 2 3 minutes cancer it again she
Catherine this I think is her work space
because she's a nurse so yeah that's
where she goes to work you also have a
lounge
Catherine where you be I guess maybe
she's in her room and then we can put
her outside her room and just wait I'm
not this game is just peeping listening
waiting but I know is just something
about of that I find really exciting
because every new characters they're
either like creepy or they're just cool
she's she's in you she's thinking about
us
[Music]
beautiful blue veins of yours
yes can't wait so excited for that how
do I use this
[Music]
oh gosh I don't know why I'm already
freaking out
how do I you like use the thing couples
and use it now anyway and Gregory's
coming l1r once change
oh my god go away Jamie oh this boy
didn't even remember how we could use
things just gonna wait here until he
gets bored or I guess I go into my room
Ashley so if you're all being chased by
anyone you can just go into your room
that's like the room in the save room
are the only safe spaces in the game
ready
go away James I think every wave runs up
and down good things done
[Music]
and this game is so iconic because
whenever I play a game that where you
have to peek I'm constantly worried
about the creaking even though it
doesn't usually happen ah I did it
okay wait stick it back up again
okay sweet let's just wait for her to
come out here more to creep why no you
you you slip on that you slip on that
banana peel you slippery yeah yeah
[Music]
oh my gosh it's such a good idea yes he
may be the cat can eat James hurry that
hammers at the end let's go see naked
zombie
[Music]
look patterns on the wall path if she
gets you it
good it's gone my soul it's gone kid
must have taken it now I'm really angry
[Music]
oh yeah you'll be forced to watch a
horror show so basically one has like a
different way to kill you and then you
watch as as a cutscene and that's a
horror show
and you do about it simple just run away
yes you can't kill them you don't have
any of weapons and you're going to hear
the power of your beliefs is everything
there it is the sanity meter a mental
gauge metric gain of mind drops to zero
we'll never be able to escape from this
place I saved the worst for last
yes sorry about that
[Music]
yes so you can go to sleep to punish it
you can get herps
of course just like any good horror game
you can get a green hair and you can you
read books folks always help reading
novels and represents the strength of
your mind whenever you're carrying a
soul it'll resonate with your mind and
make it stronger than what means you
have to consider when you're going to do
[Music]
when you're starting please roll it's
use an herb item to restore your mental
power okay reading a good book yes you
can actually increase your mental gauge
[Music]
am I telling you all this I'm just
worried thanks naked zombie Mara they'll
be going after judgement voice so yeah
yes you know my name judgement
oh my god no
judgment drink boy came to the hotel to
pass final judgment on troubled hearts I
did a good job today
now go back to your room get some rest
Mauro's another big day what what are
you guys saying she's using your ps4
controllers or thoughts an emulator
yeah I'm using PCs sex
- playing this okay so now we have to be
careful because Katherine oh oh yes of
course
Venus gives back us all so like she said
you can actually keep us all on you
which will stop your mental gage going
down as badly but I don't think I ever
did that as a kid because if you get
caught by anyone straight away they will
take the soul back again and then you
have to do everything that you just did
to get that soul and after everyone is
chasing you and after you and James is
always there and brother it just takes
forever to do that side I usually just
give it straight away to dance because
then if you get caught yeah it's game
over and whatever but you can just
reload from your savegame again actually
what does happen is it game over no I
think you you just get teleport back to
your room I don't know I'm sure we'll
find out hey idiom thanks for following
appreciate it yeah you down there I can
see it yes let's go see you
[Music]
oh it's you did you manage to pick up
any Souls
[Music]
oh you only brought me one
I take it
yeah
[Music]
hey thanks a lot here I'll stamp your
card for you to come
[Music]
just so you know guys something's going
up with my research chop better start
getting ready to receive the new guest
nice
yeah what is happening here I don't know
I can't see any of the chat it's just
like I tried to reset up it's just
loading yeah
the voices inside my head they hurt this
is um so what you just have is voices
from like your real life and your
memories kind of haunting you in the
afterlife I think we can all relate to
something like that okay uh can someone
like right in the chat just so
apparently it's working in but I still
can't see anything
but it's probably just reset completely
um so hopefully I'll be able to see you
guys the restream just stopped working
but hopefully the I don't think the
streams did
[Music]
you're nothing like Tom this is too real
all the voices right shut up
ah why aren't you working no no no no
[Music]
this is
[Music]
hey it wouldn't technology fails on you
restring come on
[Music]
yeah my my stream still working
I just can't kind of see the chat though
it says it's ready to display the chart
but I can't see anything coming in so I
am not believing it
and it doesn't even give me an option to
write to you guys definitely it's not
working oh oh there it is
[Music]
I'm just writing something to see if
it's I can see mine I just can't see any
of you guys maybe you're just not she
told me maybe maybe no one's bad this is
I have zero views this is not right
something's happening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I'm live on both YouTube and you
guys just got that okay I'm gonna have
to just give me a second I'm gonna have
to get up the twitch chat and YouTube
chat and then try and like align them so
I can see them both this is gonna be
interesting
did you do can I pop out
pop out chat pop out yeah it's it popped
out the twitch chat and then I'm gonna
pop out the YouTube chat glad you guys
still there then that's good about this
one
six
[Music]
sorry if this is triggering anyone hey
all of these like you got to do a little
better all right think about it yourself
come
whereas where is the chat oh my gosh I
bought too many things up
boop-boop
I hate not working with the mouse I had
to take my mouse out to use the
controller and now I'm like you seem a
bit we'll try it bad Oh perfect
almost okay
hey Jack games I did computer games arts
that you need if you want to hear all
about my uni stuff just watch my latest
video it's all about that so it's good
timing
okay
I think this is the best I can do sweet
we've worked our way around it so okay
now
hey Tanya and ya tu 369 thanks for
following me on Twitch yeah so this is a
really cool memo book
is that the tents yeah is that how I say
it tents yeah
yeah this is the member book where you
get to know everyone routines and I
think they change every time a new
person comes but I'm not too sure we'll
find out though and just you what times
they do certain things and you need to
be spying on them to figure out their
profile to know and the more you know
where everyone's gonna be the better you
can plan out your plan of action and
also you can hear back to what they were
saying as well so if they have any clues
so you can kind of jot it down and then
see it it's your boy thanks for
following me on twit yeah now I'm live I
need to make a cool animation but yeah I
just I really like it I just I just I
just think it's so unique to have a game
that's primarily about sneaking and
writing down things cute little Pikachu
emerging hype pipehype know that yetis
pay it back oh you made a glad
hey brought on TV yes we are back now
you are back now you never went but just
the restream just decided to start
working for some weird reason okay
and we need to collect some books is
they're gonna help with a mental gauge I
think you meant to gauge doesn't go down
in your room either
oh yeah it's judgement welcome to I know
my name
[Music]
and all your your the new gas here
aren't you now that I look at you more
closely I see you've got an awful lot on
your mind um whoever wants my help
just bring a symbol of your problem
problem I'll give you one of my special
judgments blood
I remember this actually confused the
hell out of me I think it's a certain
book that we've gotta find but yeah what
would your symbol of your problems be if
you had to bring one to someone
[Music]
oh yeah I'm not gonna break it I'm not
there is a surprise coming up you guys
will find it funny
[Music]
Catherine in here
No okay this is the funny thing oh thank
you very much yeah I will take that but
there's this a dirty book called erotic
night I'll show you what we can do with
that in a second cameras are patients
and freaking primary school Oh Chloe now
you just because something looks like a
cartoon guys does not mean that it's
suitable for kids he's talking about the
Dirty Bird by the way I'd actually know
what you need I'm gonna get back in
there in a second cuz you do need that
the books in there because obviously
they help with your mental gage and if
you collect them you can take them back
to your room and put them in your
bookcase so you can use them later on
which is pretty helpful clean have
server Oh back so as an evil can't wait
for the remake over you're excited for
the remake also what's in here
why aren't you scared I thought it was
Catherine piss oats shiza he had me if
Catherine would have heard me she would
have come straight out and sighs chasing
me I'm such a wimp even with this game
[Music]
what who what where why
I'm getting piece again female MJ
wait why oh I tried to peep in it but
Chris James is following me he's like
honey in there he's spying anyone let
you okay better off I'm going into here
oh yeah
oh no the game just crashed please no oh
god no I was going into the save room no
oh no no no oh hell no oh that she has
as well oh it actually has
I'm pressing everything trying to get us
to work okay
fine right I'm gonna have to reboot it
just give me a sec let me put back on my
nice music I'll see if I can if I can
save us yeah
I will be right back oh wait you're like
why are the candles yeah that's so true
but I should be able to press X and then
get out of this but I'm literally
pressing like every button and I can
so I don't know basically I don't know
[Music]
yeah nope nope nope okay as I was
originally saying I was fast nice music
I'll see if I can save this what we'll
see we'll see brave of the game
[Music]
get out of my mine since she left is
rotting my my let you feel what I could
not provide strips myself out but it's
not your fault I know you're not
[Music]
get out of my phone get out of my light
[Music]
storm has come to stay through the night
I'd like to say it has been nice lustful
nights just my throat don't wanna feel
[Music]
yes I'll miss you though I know you
can't see that's not like
[Music]
[Music]
get my phone get out of my mind
[Music]
[Music]
this is just a story of a cow he sort of
had seen me there Tiffa catch needing a
fresh time be careful what you say cuz
she no longer feels the same look at her
eyes and see the stains were loud
[Music]
I watched two weekend Sheila Wednesdays
but like seconds since both your paths
crossed sort of for us when I keeping
out this golf brother but he keeps him
warm but it won't last forever she likes
to think she's clever soda for an
Nichols are your words when you're so
fickle and it over her heart melted
heavy and brittle soda for a key to
regain her dignity still doll in a box
and by yours truly this is just the
story of a girl whose soul arrived
now she's forgotten she's got a fresh
start
be careful what you say cos she no
longer feels a thing look at her eyes
and see the stains below
[Music]
love can't you see that you can't even
breathe
it's here's my pinch right but your body
won't blink
I love why did you choose your salat you
can offer its eyes but you left one
loose my love as you faint I have this
2:30 sunrise was only a day was this not
breath away this is just a story of a
girl who's sort of high
now she's forgotten she's got a fresh
start
[Music]
[Music]
I will choose to child when I saw you
there you taught me how to fight
sections that just don't care and
through your lens
I saw beauty and hidden I didn't help
[Music]
since I wear Tom's arrayed in every
shadow cast and the evil eyes behind
[Music]
did it show my hope iris network win the
war will fight for freedom of system
three and on side such diverse
[Music]
[Music]
man okay guys with sign from the gang
and we're just gonna blitz through we're
just gonna blitz through it this time
we're not gonna ask any questions
resumes I'm gonna try and get back to
the point where we were because yep even
though the candles were still animating
the game was stuck so that's fun um so
yeah this is why I was gonna go into the
rabbit room devour that's not a rabbit
let's not rabbit what's wrong with me
the fog room I know it's gonna save my
game but anybody here just before just
decided not to work anymore so I'm just
gonna play it all over again that's fine
I got myself a did not finish in the fog
ships nobody cares
okay
[Music]
yeah I like I like I like I like yep
right this way every paper time baby
happy to show you to your room although
everyone in the chat seems to really
like you death okay
schedule this super quick do quick super
fast super fast I do
yeah I know right
pig pig pig pig pig
get me the key okay go go to the pass
where you the real MVP famous Jim thanks
Yangtze doji I'm so happy that someone
in the chat she knows what this game is
because this game was massive [ __ ] my
child and I loved her
which one so love it but yeah the reason
why I'm going so fast is because you've
already done all this and then I crash
so happy days we didn't get up on [ __ ]
about we just killed Katherine so what
we need killer we do this whole so oh
yeah we call the dirty magazine but we
didn't use it yes
you still go back that fun to come if
you stick around
well my orange fell on the floor
get key not the store key
[Music]
hold it I'm just gonna get my orange
Jack games is like I look like the rap
[Music]
[Music]
Catherine red unchristian content in bed
Oh true weight Gregory stop stop yeah
you're peeking
now we have all this lovely necklace on
me conversation to go through again I'm
so hungry I need to be skipper oh yeah
girl like yeah girl like I like I like
[Music]
hashtag blame James said yes II in the
twitch chat yes I do blame James it's
all days you see yeah I see
now you have to wait that's a big sweet
you have to wait for this okay
chocolate you want chocolate is it
that's it thank you do this
[Music]
I'm just fine oh no I don't want to ask
you these questions shall do let's go
back to Matt come on now throw away all
their worries
[Music]
the only bought me one hey thanks a lot
yeah it's like when you get [ __ ] till
the time of a godsend then I always lose
the card and then but missed out with so
many free copies of my okay we're
getting there
[Music]
what would he go and save our game again
we don't need to watch that twice and
one sitting I would not put you guys to
that you're welcome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mine no no go away
okay that's why I don't care a little
bit James is staying away from me boy
the game crash someone stepped on an
accident there's that brat James middle
of aphasia yes one who has to clean up
all of your messes
[Music]
who see if we can actually save this is
the saber and this is why I was supposed
to do is this game rude
sweet
yeah you'll be back I remember thinking
that was so clever as a kid cuz I was
like oh my god it's a real
fortune-teller it knows girls I'll be
back Catherine where are you at girl
[Music]
your yaga lag the one who's been
collecting souls I see that face makes
me want to do terrible things to you
take as a compliment Catherine make your
job harder by running away treat a mean
keep you keen as they say
okay so let's go get our little banana
pill she's such a death I hate running
away from people in this game because
what you can see she just runs her
slowly and the controls are so awkward
and it's just it's just a lot of stress
[Music]
no no no pick it up I wanted to use the
door okay now let's try and find
Catherine she went out of her rings I'm
guessing she might have gone around the
halls or to her workplace there's just
not in there so people won't be in a
room well the only way that you know if
someone's in a room is when the little
like speech bubbles will come out of the
doors I'm not too sure where she is
right now but I can hear something
quick quick use I'm done
Shauna who that okay who cares let's
just go grab it
we chose free speed iam no I'm come off
proud of us Oh guys go don't let anyone
find you just Courtney pick it up where
is it it's here somewhere
there it is
[Music]
he's streaming the start to finish
hell no actually fun fact I've never
finished this game I always found it way
too hard as a kick if you end up having
liked so many people after you and you
used to leave your bedroom and you're
just running around like a mad woman but
we'll see what happens
okay I can't skip it's gone
my soul in a good kid must have taken it
now I'm really angry
[Music]
oh the humanity
and you do about it a one last bound
here the power of your beliefs is
everything thank you wonder if I can
find the sounds I can you have no judge
no money hey no no hello ha I'm Italian
spaghetti um okay let's go give our soul
to death and then finally be back when
we were before the game damn worries oh
it's you did you manage to pick up any
souls
oh you only brought me one yes I know
good enough for you I take it yeah
hey thanks a lot here I'll stamp your
card for you oh thanks for subscribing
Jasmine and thanks are following Jack
rocks in Chewbacca did we see this yeah
yeah we did
oh I can't skip it anyway so we're gonna
have to watch it you well then better
start getting ready to receive the new
guest opening the doors on the ground
floors and now we can smoke
[Music]
you know my name
judgment on your yeah now that I look at
you more closely I see you've got an
awful lot on your mind um whoever wants
my help
just bring a symbol of your problem
problem I'll give you one of my special
judgments good okay now we're back to
where we were perfect love this yes
let's go this we take the dirty book and
then we get let's just save it now just
to go through any of that gun is this
game save this game yes a bit great
[Music]
yes I'm pretty sure if I find a satin
bunch which I guess it might be in here
but it would be too obvious to be in
here shite
damn it always move too much okay keep I
don't want him to come and talk to us
because he's so annoying
[Music]
there is a book there and this oh hello
you brown yo Justin see ya tough choice
but it's got his face on it but
something tells me it's not that one
oh what a day oh there's a mushroom
under there can't find it anywhere
oh yeah he's booked okay let's go give
him his book Hey
how nice to see you and what can I do
for you huh where did you find that book
[Music]
now I'm gotta go with my life it's no
use no I think you should read something
more tasteful this piece of this book
you're looking for such a book I suggest
you try the first floor library sure a
little reading will make all of your
worries melt away
[Music]
maybe that's the book you need to take
to judgment but I don't think so
but yeah he like runs but let's follow
him oh sure hopefully we don't bump into
[Music]
this doll always freaks me out in here
and he's just like got this little porn
collection here going on and there's
always like wonder what was the point
what was the point in having that Burke
I mean I guess just a bit of extra fun
yeah he's basically just they're having
fun right now it's a little dirty corner
in the sword room anyway
now I think I think I need to get to the
library as he didn't mention that so it
wouldn't make sense
hey judgment
and you can see my mental gage is going
down
and to keep an eye on that TV do you
monetize no Chewbacca this wasn't the
children's game this is what I mean I
played when I was a kid as a look like a
kids game but I don't think my mom was
pretty paying attention oh okay so what
hold up so I need to search for this
book but I need to put some stuff away
so if we go back to our room you can put
stuff in your wardrobe I don't know what
this word handkerchief is but you've had
it since you arrived apparently yes we
go bookshelf here and she almost Affairs
or but some stuff in here
now I guess I will use one of these
oh that didn't help
that's freaking okay
[Music]
okay now we just wait for the folks
Gregory expose some ratings monthly
self-help book okay so this is it this
is the book we're looking for yes there
really is no other reason for that dirty
book thing apart from a little Easter
egg and them
I guess he gives you a little clue as to
where to find this book but I'm gonna
put those books in my bookshelf now
maybe have a little sneak sneak I'm Nick
a zombie see what see what that cat's a
gherkin
NECA was a male or female I guess I
shouldn't I shouldn't gender him/her oh
my god take it myself a whole people say
he just like tips people people are
coming I'm scared to do is it I don't
want it to be I don't want you animals
carry hate I'm Williams 98 thank you so
much for the fog much appreciated he was
out here
hey the - Michaels found each other in
the chat don't know but they don't know
hey hey hey I have a book I have the
book the matter handbook book he's too
fast I can't can't talk with him or
carrying a self-help book aren't you yes
well then it's time to judge which path
your future will take charming young
woman who's accidentally wandered into a
hotel through another dimension
the bringer thank you only one way to
get back to the real world you must
collect lost souls the hotel's full of
danger you can't run and you can't ride
so what do you do know I do I do
run and hide that is literally I'm here
to move this game and buggy then let's
ask the scales off to root who which
will it be money or love only the scales
know for sure
[Music]
he dropped the Donnell sign this shuttle
into details about a house top fin
stocks you'll never kill pop yes
although I did I'll give you a I think
judgment boy is the only one that like
doesn't try to kill you after you take a
soul because you didn't necessarily
steal it off him you had to you know do
this thing with him so he's alright
so if we still only have to worry about
Katherine right now but if I am correct
every personal thing after this tricycle
you said it gets quite difficult quite
quickly
it's such a cool idea to have your
memories kind of like play back to you
in your bedroom as well bad thoughts you
know my things that you wish you had
done when you were still alive I think
who did I get to I think I used to get
to like TV fish which TV fish was super
freaking cool Gregory that child that
just moved in is so adorable
my Catherine you certainly know quality
when you see it oh I've just got to get
some of
let's not be hasty it's lively and
spirited Oh your mother will be thrilled
indeed she will but remember Catherine
neither dead nor alive Catherine are you
listening to me
this time I'll make sure there's no
escape maybe I should go with caffeine
for next Halloween like no and I was
like it lets me change you with like a
little love heart but I think around a
giant need to hide this secret from Mama
the can't you just be quiet oh dear oh
dear why can't you just be quiet you're
upsetting our guests
I hope you can get out soon
[Music]
me too me too
see you next it's on me next time is a
good one right along look so now because
we can actually go it says well we can
go now yeah I already need to start
spying on people also I can start
putting out my memo book oh my god this
one is so sweet you guys told me you are
feeling
[Music]
adios Senor eater may you be happy
someday okay
micro says we freaked out me to play
this when you're again yeah definitely I
mean I quite enjoyed it though
so this is around the time when I need
to sneak around my friend's house to
play alone in the darkened new nightmare
and I think it was Sun Hill as well so
kind of used to horror games my mom had
no idea of course but just the way it's
just the way it is that's it so I would
be scared for biscuit yeah I enjoy them
it's more like on edge just nervous all
the time cuz you're always like where
are the people that are gonna kill me
like right now it's also bags just that
one person but uh yeah it's it gets
scary later on you have to keep before
entering anywhere just in case hmm
family favorite character cactus gunman
I don't blame you
if they're singing it's usually James I
wanna move too fast okay man come out
and bug me yeah see I told you [ __ ]
people that's what he does
no I'm not gonna be one of you leave me
alone
I don't want this
I've no edema Catherine is already like
sadly okay these are too new the idea
for that character is partying all right
that counts in the ill so Catherine's
always looking after them - she's a
nurse but you know you can kinda see why
they have a headache all the time
Jacqueline was looking a little pale
that's just me that's who I am don't be
rude
special medicine yeah cuz they still
have a shadow so holding us all can we
get better of course I'm not going to
give it to you oh I mean to be fair it
is actually helping them get better so
you're kind of being a bit selfish a
playing this game i'm just taking other
souls so that I can hopefully get back
to the real world but what about them
what if they want to go back to the real
world a not thinking about that now
I'm scared that I'm gonna run into the
hawk
friend because this is her work place
oh she's back actors done cannot be
caught cannot be caught can I be caught
no don't keep in there like go in there
[Music]
[Music]
nobody
od to keep you waiting
you
she's biting me cactus Cameroon oh no oh
no oh he guns hey hi nice to meet you I
love his room though we're gonna go up
to the new rooms there I just saw a
comment it was yeah but on TV saying
this hey miss Cooper it looks a bit
repetitive I can't what you mean why I
guess it doesn't feel that way because
every time a new character comes it's
like holding back story to learn like
whole new character to learn put a
personality whole new like room like new
rooms that open up and how much kind of
keeps you playing cuz it's a basement as
well it's not just two floors it's it's
actually quite a big place and I don't
mind I've always been more of a gamer
who's like I'm very happy to sit back
and just look at all the details I don't
need things to be that fast-paced all
the time and in fact I should kind of
noise me if it's fast-paced others right
so I guess it's just what kind of games
you enjoy playing
did I finish who dat who dat
no one's gonna kill me with this go run
run run
hmm
my mental gauge is going down he said
eat some things put it back up what was
that noise where are the will I like
that this game has a distinctive
personality yeah it really does I mean
like I said before but I think I said
before you got here Michael injustice
this is based off a Japanese cartoon you
should if you like the art style and
stuff like you should definitely check
out it looks like zap you like this
exactly you know what guys let's go
upstairs let's go look upstairs we still
have some rooms to check out done yeah
but I want to show you upstairs I really
want to show you cactus gunman's broom
whoo dad oh my god this this one is so
freaky like she she's the one that
scares me the most in this whole game
she's absolutely terrifying
[Music]
what she pressed me in a nightmare
already I haven't even taken a soul yeah
oh I don't remember this this is really
what happens when anyone catches you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this game is really cool when you
when anything like that happens or see
you've got hit tiredness headache
nervousness fusion melech only darkness
different things happen with the game
mechanics when these things happen to
you so basically I remember every single
one brother like with darkness you won't
see as much on the screen there's one of
them I think it's confusion where the
controls get reversed and with some of
them the only way you can kill yourself
is by sleeping you can't do it by by um
eating things so I don't know why she
could already do that before I've even
taken a freaking soul but she's scary
because she's a little girl and she just
sits in her room while outside her room
crying looking for this doll but the
doll is actually stitched to the back of
her head and like it's just terrifying
okay let's go into our room and check it
out
doors held tightly shut by the force of
the lost dolls fight wow that's great
but oh let's save the game quickly and
then I'll show you Texas guns
[Music]
so we let's go bad
Michael oh is that some comment it's
uncommon wait what
this isn't the room that I was thinking
of he's oh yeah so cactus Cameron is a
hopeless romantic this is why I love
what scheme they all have really
distinct personalities and he's actually
in love with us
i-i've never paid as a male before maybe
I should have because I want to see if
he would have been in love with us the
male as well because they're like that
would be very progressive for the time
but as you can see I'm on the wall and
I'm like here or maybe it would maybe it
would be seen as like he hates me
actually if I was on the target board
but because I'm a girl he's like also
Anita and he's like always trying to
flirt with me and stuff oh she's back
she is say anything
[Music]
okay let's wait
oh yeah cool find her a doll cuz that's
what she's looking for the doll why do
you have to stay in front of your room
scared the bad guys will come steal my
treasure Oh what okay fine I'll get you
a doll or something like that this might
be the very most trying to show you guys
yes how cool is this my brother the
coolest guy that's up thank you come on
sister
yeah yeah yeah collide my name is Katja
gel I'm character down until seven
you're the one who's been persecuting my
mother I won't let them get away with it
wait a minute this is my hometown the
Badlands of the all wet my brother I'll
leave you alone for now and respect for
my brother do what I mean this game is
just this is you can't really expect
what's gonna happen next
I don't know she actually leave the room
hey bong bong is that how you say it
cook Bom
okay now I'm just going to figure out so
I've gotta get that oh oh it's only you
give me your soul you're gonna get a
doll for her I think maybe like medicine
or some things for the adults something
yeah
ah the medicine won't work as well
because I'm nervous I I probably should
just go go back to bed me everyday
um yeah I probably should just go by its
best so if you go back to bed I think
the jukebox
yeah let's go down the rubbish chute
guys it's full of blood why not
she's so unhappy she's like why you do
this to me why you make me do this what
are we doing who who is it I don't know
I'm scared I'm just going this way okay
I'm gonna go back
that my nervousness goes away because
I'm pretty sure when mania is going down
pretty fast because of it as well
[Music]
hey Joe Adams like it's kind of
refreshing to see a game you don't have
to kill everything yes I agree and I
like it a lot and I laughed that's also
why I already loved beyond good and evil
as well because it was like taking
pictures and stuff as well as just
killing things are you gonna play a
different game every time you stream I'm
not sure like maybe I think so
I'm not too sure I'm just seeing what
what happens basically I'm already
planning it pop from Thursday I'm gonna
play dad debt by daylight because I
would play with my friend Tom but apart
from that I don't really know I know I
definitely want to try and play the
third high pot again but I can't find a
good buy so for it but I'm thinking I
might play that on Christmas Eve is that
it's like my Christmas game yeah why
isn't my nervousness not gone
maybe I'll have to wait it buckles and
things I was only through hair that can
cure it
I have anything relax is here relax is
here pressure squeeze something hmm
maybe I'll try reading a police
hmm yeah sure why not
[Music]
no I'm still nervous no well screw it
we're just gonna do this being nervous
the whole into that sign so let's figure
out
I didn't look before I laughed that
could have been bad but then again I
could just turn brown and I'm liking
that
so let's look at the shot so I'll tell
you guys this shop as I got home good
reason here this is what we need
[Music]
okay
yep okay so now we have Vee doll we can
probably go do something what a levels
did I take said jerkings I didn't
actually I just college it was like
media studies but during my Media
Studies I was like I actually asked him
if I could change my set modules and I
did a games design one
[Music]
yeah thank you see if we can trust my
Kara why do you why do you guys want a
snack oh good die oh god is this
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
gonna pass out my headache oh that's
I students going through slavery right I
didn't know what I was doing
Oh keep talking ducks
oh my god these controls now I can
[Music]
great
now I'm gonna be worse than ever
[Music]
okay good at least I'm not I thought I'd
be like really bad pot I need that so we
need to figure out a way that we can
make the dog so yeah well that's so like
oh you kidding me
do you see why I've never completed this
game uh testing you have to be so
careful you literally have to pee pal
every day
[Music]
[Music]
please contain yourself okay
Oh doesn't work it knows
okay let's let's read a book good book
there we go
hey this area is like to die it's in the
night
[Music]
[Music]
so we just go let's go strap says white
guys
it's the strip size and get the doll
oh we haven't been on this side of the
upstairs yet nice big double bed I don't
know it seems to be like a special item
burr it's not in our special item stuff
so I don't know if I ever got to the
point where I was able to get into this
gold room but look at it because
obviously we're still waiting for guests
to arrive and don't don't forget there's
more than just this there's a whole
basement as well on the basement is
freaking huge guys so big
skin dark yeah it does see that actually
so when as the time goes to like really
late it does get darker as well God who
what where why What Huh What huh he was
it I'm good whatever I don't care right
I just don't know okay I'm gonna save
the game prize I don't know if I talked
over there with the doll I don't know
she's still gonna Z with this game okay
what do you think guys should we just
drop it
wait who what where I see this like
should I give it to her I'm just too
scared
thanks very much
tall girl you're so freakin creepy scare
the hell out of me
oh that's a treasure of course well that
means that makes perfect sense
her room is quite sweet though you got
to admit that let me let me know blow me
to let me take let me take
okay no let's go to sleep and give this
till someone comes and takes it cuz I
hope I don't have to do that again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna torture can we pick up the
book again yeah we got the dirty book I
guess maybe that's just the way to get
all five K's Oh
okay so he's gonna he's gonna sleep
patterns of stairs judgment boys there
[Music]
you both have swords in your heads
so they fall down so maybe it's just a
banana peel trick again
but I don't think you can do the same
thing again can you I don't know fall
down in the Jacuzzi jacuzzi hmm
so maybe they just randomly fall down at
certain time in the jacuzzi which
actually is in the room back up we'll go
there in a bit and then um
oh he's watching his western shows hey
it seemed like the hot bath word again
you got to his heat okay so it is yeah
let's go check it out
Opel's who what where I can't tell what
room where is it because we hear someone
[Music]
so do I just have to wait then to come
in here just doesn't seem right it seems
like an action you have to do something
every time right right
alright another one is a mushroom in
here hey Berger Leo crates
laughing mushrooms Oh interesting
take doesn't do anything
also I don't want can I just Chuck this
jump that I don't want to lap pretty
sure that makes me ill since this salad
not Caesar salad it's scissors salad
damn it's so dark
okay guys Oh cousin sleeping let's let's
see what she's dreaming about
[Music]
for days I'll drop ya they do just pass
out on the jacuzzi oh whoa thanks for
subscribing James whoops here appreciate
it welcome to the community we're small
but we use mighty or I'll catch you and
eat you oh my god okay I'm I'm not
coming in there just when you freaking
scared me
oh hey Robin just wanted to say hey love
perfection love specter lurking thanks
so much I'm actually working on a new
update I'm just really worried that it's
not gonna work I need to get some people
to beta test it so I'll probably ask my
patreon but thank you and also it will
be on Mac and Linux
when I get sorted as well
[Music]
if you did welcome 2,000 twitch chat by
the way okay so that's good sleep and
give this song hey thanks a lot yeah
I'll stamp your card for you hey you
don't know just go
yeah we just got two more to go how did
I never complete this as a kid and then
I get I was a kid in primary school so I
guess I don't know just a member this
gave me absolutely horrendously hard
[Music]
yeah you get little figurines as well
which is super cute and I get to change
their oh no I don't how many of those ad
changer animations
[Music]
I already appreciated
[Music]
[Music]
so we've got it basically just follow
the dogs around we wait for them to be
that Catherine wait for them to be
passed out around the jacuzzi is missing
his owner passed always since been to
prison that's true words true words even
tapped his jeonghwan lips to pass
through rose-tinted glasses
wait no hurry up yes I bet he just seen
everyone what about everyone what does
the same thing what okay that doesn't
make sense I think you're gonna give me
a really good clue about gunman but you
didn't
there's now we're gonna look up the two
people we gotta look out for the lost
doll as well James Mason [ __ ] around
again I know my papa has been facing all
over the place I know but never where I
need to be
all right Gregory
okay I'm gonna save the game yes I'm one
of those fornicators but especially what
happened to the beginning this dream I
do not want it to happen again
[Music]
okay fingers crossed if we're lucky
they'll be in there right now but I've
already doubt it I just realized that's
Gregory's mom that statue she could grab
that hair up anyways well where'd it go
I know we're gonna see it's over here
hmm where mommy they never you ratajczak
doing okay let's try and spy on people
or at least let's get hints for cactus
gunmen if we can't get handsome
[Music]
I know but I want you to fade now
[Music]
aw [ __ ] wait nothing
mummy Papa look make sense when we dog a
mummy okay that was money or be enough
maybe they'll just faint if I go and
stare because it already Busey
you guys are faint maybe if I just like
chase them fainting
I think guys faint
[Music]
okay so I'm very we're fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you gonna go in the hot tub now you
see they are a shock wave it's a game
called Gregory's Horror Show or gregory
horror show please say no no John knows
me Tom asked me tell Matt I'm not here
sneaky
Oh someone's in love in here what the
how's this
I was comin again she's [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my gosh comes she's gonna go don't
better this way please don't be this way
she came out to see if I was checking on
her she ain't going
what are you doing a James
skull-and-crossbones mark
ooh where did you find that I want that
I think I need that
keep that to me hopefully she won't come
outside this time what
hey Tom this is like one of my favorite
games as a kid it was like a game that
looks like it should be for kids but
it's really so I need to get into the
springs some well don't know how don't
even that cuz using that they're ready
to take some stuff because I was slow to
go and crazy expired cheese I already
don't want to eat that everyone just
keeps saying I need to get into the
spring so I don't know oh it's that it's
right on the second table so just go in
and get it what I wake them up what are
you guys think yeah I'm gonna go
[Music]
well that was easy it's taking me
sleeping of course nice and just sneak
out there now what back to my room I
guess now we just need cactus gunmen
okay okay I know he's a hopeless
romantic that's about all I know about
him right now but I'm sure if we spy on
people they'll tell us how to how to get
it
no eyes Chewbacca thanks so much for
coming
oh look before you go we have a new
figurine wait wait wait for her
where's her needle one here we go
freaking crazy Catherine with a needle
so happy so ecstatic that's to kill love
that blood okay let's get some sleep
[Music]
don't wave really likes bullets at me
say nice element right up just had
really bad things though but I'm sure we
better after baby yes
yoni popping John huh yeah
[Music]
okay and now now we have to watch out
for Katherine the last stole girl and
both mummy Papa and daddy Papa whatever
I think that's what they're called so
and we need to figure out how we're
gonna get a cactus gun when the soul
what kind of minecraft is this
that reminds me today I had my little
niece over and we were watching the
interactive minecraft show on Netflix I
think I was way more into it than she
was but it's actually really cool if you
get to make all the decisions and stuff
uh of course NECO here does enough food
as per usual my stomach still feels
empty maybe I should give him some food
oh yeah Tom um so my restream stopped
working I don't really know why but it's
not working today but so I've just got
the both twitch and YouTube streams like
pops yeah chats popped up by Chewbacca
[Music]
my let's give you some food
I just refreshed it but oh I just
refreshed it and it says it's connected
now so hey there you go guys she'll be
working now so what did you say there's
a coward the bigger the gun he doesn't
realize what he really is he just keeps
giving yourself the best things to do
with a coward like that is to uncover
the true nature of his fears how how am
I supposed to do that
give him the exotic erotic night
magazine exotic night
no matter how many times I think
I never gets out of the sound cool with
you gentle boy yeah it's working I raise
it with some pals after I finished my
stream there I'm not sure if they stuck
around thanks but I know just which
needs that I have no idea what means yep
no idea what that means but the thanks
appreciate it okay so he went around the
corner right because that's a guy that
I've gotta watch out for now because I'm
making so many enemies in this game
let's save yeah I let you meet like what
bits was yesterday cuz I was like why
can't I give you bits and I was like
what what and then I realized it has to
be a Twitter video game or partner which
I am neither
last oh go go go go go boom boom
making enemies is bad but yeah yes
usually usually is quite bad Oh
see they just passed up again they just
pass out everywhere apparently scares me
although all the doors are just so loud
wouldn't happen get eat that the third
time than the first one like when
breakfast and lunch go alright yeah Lots
doors like um if you're really being
serious okay so he gets the runs after
dinner does that help me in any way
maybe I need to be down by the food and
waiting for him to have a damn Joe Adams
what's your plan for Christmas food
anything special as we know this is
gonna be already weird Christmas like
all my family are going elsewhere for
Christmas well if not all my family
obviously so it like usually it's like
with my step family and my grandma and
stuff but they're all going elsewhere so
it's just gonna be me my brother my mom
and my stepdad and my mom doesn't even
want to do a roast
because she's trying to do like
Christmas on a different day because she
wants everyone to be there I don't know
so knowing my family it's just gonna be
a lot of drinking why did I just jump
like nothing happened
give me a lot of drinking and I bought
my mum's little games because she loves
Christmas like so much and she's so down
that no one's coming but yeah it should
be good I've brought some games that we
can all play on Christmas Day so should
be fun we're trying to like help how
what's she trying to help out like a
homeless shelter or something just so
like do something nice on the day oh
yeah I was gonna make it [ __ ] what are
you what are you guys saying you guys do
anything fun
[Music]
James can bugger off you wouldn't that
she's so annoying
dude good down by the toilet if there is
one since the runs I don't know good
idea shockwave bah I don't actually
think use the toilet that's a really
good idea though but yeah I really don't
think there's a toy in this game anyway
alright Michael thanks for coming
[Music]
as some friendly advice stay with you
wanna play this luckily my family don't
play Monopoly I don't either I get way
too invested can I put something in here
kind of get something put it in the
dinner or something I don't know
hoody heard this I got a Malan
we should remember something I've just
got to keep spying on people and see
what they say
this meat what was that
I wish I could just turn the camera
around
I don't want to hear about the cat I
want to hear about a gunman what about
boy you don't have to chase him away
from what room
well that sounds nice Joe having your
family that's more about being together
than presents I agree stuff anymore
about that I guess it just gets hard
once your family starts pissing off and
you know having partners and stuff and
going over partners and my my grandma
has a partner as well so like they have
to alternate between who's family you
gonna spend Christmas with together all
I've learned is that cactus Cameron has
the runs after dinner that's great how
are they gonna help me oh yeah what's
the news well done Yaga lag thank you
[Music]
it was just the fact that I got two
souls on top of the true nature of his
beard oh how am I gonna do that
digi sub two pews I've been sucked
subject to boots since amnesia days guys
so yes
[Music]
[Music]
you go to sleep cuz then everyone will
be in different places okay now it's
pretty late
yep so it's gonna be super a freaking
dark I know there is no choice in this
game I totally should have checked
what's the story to the game so far so
basically you're a a lost soul I guess
she's kind of died but this hotel is
limbo and the only way to get back to
reality is by stealing other people's
souls but they're not really their souls
just souls that they've stolen a way so
I guess that's a morality thing of the
games and not make you feel too bad
about taking the souls and but once you
take a soul that person then tries to
kill you if they see you again upstairs
and I've got one more soul to get to go
onto the next part of this so every like
parts its if they're called Knights but
it's usually multiple nights you get new
gas at the hotel and they all have their
own Souls and you have to take them
Souls but you have to learn about them
as a person to know what their
weaknesses are gasps and you can know
you can find out that by peeping on
people and sneaking and watching them
and mister lost dog here
very sad oh thank you lost all she just
gave us the answer so we put a show that
he's scared
is it he is not as macho as he thinks he
is so basically we've gotta wait until
he's in his room and we're not gonna
draw and scare him but that's okay we
can't do that till he's in his room
obviously soon well just wait to get by
on people on the process
Oh Oh God
get away get away get away get away I
don't want you it's Catherine it's
Catherine get away get away get away
lively attitude does that mean having
such a low coming back to life no means
coming back to life I know you're not
asking too many questions don't ask away
[Music]
why do you know carefully a Gregory
House original once you take one home
with a souvenir why would you need a
kettle over time that can actually vary
so I know
[Music]
yes thank you I'm gonna use that now we
can jump in time he cause he can't see
who's outside that brat is definitely
stoned I can totally see where you get
that assumption from
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she's in her room
[Music]
so I have to just wait for him to come
back in his room I guess Craig's a
dealer confirmed
[Music]
yeah oh these I'll tell you about
everything that I said in the menu so if
you get headache your head with foot
pain you can come up by headache lemony
nervous justa Michael get upset your
recovery items on behalf selectively a
new way and notice that and kill this
with the and tactic
next comes confusion your head will
start to spin you won't know which way
you're going
yeah that's the most annoying thing cuz
the controls go backwards
FBI bust through yak storm know your
needs to get selected to come yourself
even people say to ailments with
medicine unless you get some rest you're
just like this again
and then there's darkness that's when
everything it does automatically when
you get into pretty dark places and also
between 12:00 a.m. and 6:00 a.m. but if
you use some eyedrops you'll get rid of
the duck if someone steals assault from
you overcome melancholy you'll get
depressed and won't have the energy to
run the best medicine phonetically is
laughter you'll feel better dear oh I do
have life insurance
[Music]
and then you can be tired as well see we
have so many different mechanics and
it's sort of everything so stop this
going up to
[Music]
wait come again sir she won't come in
here thank you for following GG Lindsay
appreciate it
[Music]
taxes man where you at small shook
frames like and Mississippi underwater
likes gone up now you definitely know I
have met some people that do you like it
all you know still find it quite fun so
you're not the only one don't worry
[Music]
[Music]
this is read for time for again
[Music]
okay and no one's out here cuz it's
clear let's go
[Music]
what about in here here's someone but I
can't see anyone screw it let's go
[Music]
oh the doles must be downstairs I'm like
it I keep hearing doors and I'm just
like such a tense game
hey Whittier hey yak remember Reaper
Reaper no I don't really
can you please bugger off like I need to
just knock on his door
[Music]
scaring me like that
right after a few turns quiet
uh-huh there's such a risk I wonder if
they thought about this when they were
developing this part today I'm not just
noting the Dorgan okay this is gonna be
third time lucky we got this guy's thou
art Reaper he was had I don't remember
him am I supposed to
[Music]
this is good it's a mere yak man yo ass
nightmare
Oh get it gonna get again no you go to
turn around honey
she got senator brown honey companies
don't take it
people take it they'll take it I just
gonna please don't
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
she's gonna take my soul guys she's
gonna take it No
[Music]
[Music]
beside wait so now who has the soul did
it go to her or did it go back to him
like what happened
yeah that was some bad luck like that
bones they do definitely have it wait
twice to have it the same person come to
get you
if sir than I am but a lucky duck do I
still have myself
[Music]
hey thanks a lot yeah I stamp your card
for you nice and now you get to see some
new ones and you guys my controller
would be like
see flames four days of deepest freezes
you shall soon be consumed by the flames
of room what are you babbling about what
a complete load of baloney you cannot
escape your fate judgment here we have a
hotel manager truck to the prophecy of
doom what will you do what will you do
[Music]
for the love of I'm surrounded by idiots
Gregory your mother was looking for you
I don't remember being summoned
so are you hiding something or is your
conscience clear what
Gregori my conscience is clear
I'm not hiding anything from Mama yo-yo
because of you your mama's precious
Souls was stolen you're in deep trouble
[Music]
to explain yeah but I never go to the
[Music]
[Music]
basement
[Music]
[Applause]
the secret is in the sauce
smoking the scenes
try to remember like I don't know see we
haven't really done much sneaking
picking up Burke's 10 to 12 doing this
working in front desk
front desk is a mess sitting in the room
completely bonkers in a stupor hungry
sitting in a room quietly I don't know
what the difference between red and
green is fine oh I guess like dangerous
but then why is never gonna be always
red anyway I'm gonna go now too cuz I
need to make some brick that's some
breakfast
Debbie not I need to make some dinner
but thanks guys everyone for coming
am i shiny like sing you a little
Christmas before any weird I thought I
used to do I don't I haven't sang that
much like recently cuz I've been working
on the game and stuff but then it's
weird because I've been working on the
EP like all the artwork for it but I
haven't been singing so I was like maybe
you should end today's stream River that
will sing you something so but first of
all let's save the game and maybe I'll
carry this time tomorrow because I will
be streaming tomorrow as well so make
sure you follow me on Twitter and I
might tweet out and ask if you guys want
to see more of this
if not I'll probably play it in my own
time anyway because I really wanna
finish
[Music]
[Music]
okay um is anyone still here
is there any point me do you want me to
sing before I go or should I just go oh
what's the time anyway
it's half was eight that's not so bad
all right so nobody's chained but people
are still here I know you're here I know
you're here I might just be on the
background to be fast so I will sing you
a little song before I go and don't
forget to follow me on Twitter to find
out what's gonna happen tomorrow what
game I'm gonna play and stuff but ya
know
[Music]
Hey
yet here wants to everything hi dreaming
of a white Christmas just like the ones
I used to know where the treetops
glisten and children listen to hear
sleigh bells in the snow
[Music]
I'm dreaming why Christmas with every
Christmas card I write your days be
merry and bright and may all your
Christmases be white I'm dreaming of a
white Christmas just like the ones I
used to know
[Music]
where the treetops with Sun and children
the Sun to hear sleigh bells in the snow
[Music]
ah dreamy why Christmas with every
Christmas card I write may your days be
merry and bright and may all your
Christmases Merry Christmas or happy
holidays that's more appropriate to say
nowadays but I will see you tomorrow
make sure that you're following me on
Twitch no well twitch and YouTube and
remember on there and Twitter
of course because that's where I will be
letting you know what game I'm going to
play and do let me know if you want to
see more of this or if you want me play
a different game tomorrow so I will see
you then have a lovely day or evening I
will say goodbye to who I can see in the
chat right now so if you want me to say
goodbye to you say goodbye right now
goodbye
yeah yeah goodbye yeah III 69 goodbye
super hadn't goodbye yeah Yeti and yeah
here that's all I can see in the chat
and to everyone who isn't in the chat
but is like lurking
good bye TT so I will see you hopefully
tomorrow or maybe some other time in the
week I'm streaming every day up until
Friday and then I'll be streaming on
Christmas Eve as well Oh goodbye you
cats and goodbye Tom puck thank you very
much have a lovely evening